im studio begrüße ich jetzt hendrik wies
ministerpräsident von
nordrhein-westfalen schönen guten abend
sorgen was machen sie denn so
normalerweise um 2 uhr 37 also
üblicherweise schlafe ich da und
gefüttert wird abend sowieso nicht mehr
sollte dann einem minister zu dieser
zeit informationen verteilen überhaupt
zu dieser zeit so wichtige
entscheidungen treffen
ich glaube wir brauchen klarheit und
verlässlichkeit in der pandemie politik
und dieses hin und her und dann talkshow
und twitter ist alles der sache nicht
dienlich die entscheidung zu revidieren
das ist richtig vorher was anderes zu
wollen ist nicht richtig dass alles so
hektisch zu machen ist erst recht nicht
richtig die menschen müssen sie schon
auf das verlassen können was wir sagen
die pandemie ist nicht vorbei die
menschen brauchen klare regeln ja das
haben wir gelernt in dieser pandemie wo
es vielerorts einen klaren regeln
gefehlt hat jetzt zurück zu dieser ja
doch nicht beendigung der quarantäne
pflicht spricht das nicht auch dafür
dass ein vertrauen in die bürger fehlt
hat der gesundheitsminister kein
vertrauen in die bürger das müssen sie
ihn wahrscheinlich am besten selber
fragen aber es ist ja auch eine frage
wie man dann mit solcher freiwilligkeit
umgeht da wird der eine krank ist
infiziert und geht arbeiten der nächste
sagt du ich gehe jetzt lieber mal
freiwillig in quarantäne schefter sagt
der chef auf welcher grundlage willst du
denn jetzt hier nicht arbeiten gehen
also wir brauchen ja auch verlässliche
regeln für den umgang miteinander und
die allermeisten menschen wollen doch
klare regeln haben an die sie sich auch
halten das erlebt ja jeder von uns auch
im bekanntenkreis wenn man infektions
ist will man ja auch nicht andere
anstecken und deswegen ist dieses dieses
signal ausgeht doch alle laufen und
macht mal was er wollte ja auch falsch
gewesen insofern in der sache richtig
entschieden in der art und weise
kommunikativ ein desaster wir brauchen
ruhe und nicht dieses hin und her hin
und her auch so ein bisschen bei den
masken jeder verliert den überblick was
geht nun im supermarkt darf man
eigentlich ohne viele supermärkte sagen
aber doch selbe situation in den schulen
wie handhaben sie persönlich das wenn
sie einkaufen gehen dann mit maske oder
ohne also ich persönlich trage im
supermarkt noch maske auch da wo
ungeregelt menschen zusammenkommen und
man nicht so genau weiß würde ich es
immer machen und ich empfehle das auch
allen anderen ansonsten sind die regeln
sowie der bund ist gewollt hat das die
massen pflicht fast überall weggefallen
ist also im prinzip die masken pflicht
weggefallen aber jeder trägt sie noch
das wird auch das ist eine erinnerung an
freiwilligkeit so hat der buntes gewand
die länder wollten einen basisschutz das
war einigkeit über alle parteigrenzen
hinweg in der konferenz der
ministerpräsidentin und
ministerpräsidenten wir wollten
eigentlich ein basis schutzmasken
pflicht auf abstand halten noch immer da
wenn es nötig ist beibehalten der bund
hat das anders gewollt jetzt muss ja
auch die verantwortung für das
übernehmen was jetzt passiert dafür gibt
es jetzt die hotspots regelungen da
kocht dann auch jedes bundesland sein
eigenes süppchen und konzentriert sich
dann wieder auf die zahlen von dem man
eigentlich weiß dass hier nichts taugen
dass sie nicht aussagekräftig sind so
zumindest hat es auch der
gesundheitsminister wieder gesagt und
das führt weiterhin so kam es auch an
den schulen maske an maske auf viele
schulen halten weiter an der masken
pflicht fest ihr kind ist noch ein
bisschen zu jung für die show dennoch
was würden sie sagen wenn neben ihrer
tochter dann ein kind sitzt und sagt ich
sitze nicht neben dir weil du keine
maske als oder ich will nicht neben dir
sitzen weil du die maske weiterhin
trägst wo bringen wir unsere kinder in
was für eine situation bringen wir sie
da also uns wäre als ländern viel viel
lieber gewesen wir hätten auch da noch
die möglichkeit selber schnell zu
entscheiden der expertenrat der
bundesregierung hat genau das auch von
uns als politik gefordert die
bundesregierung hat sich für einen
anderen weg entschieden
die hotspot regelung ist kein geeignetes
mittel damit umzugehen weil sie knüpft
eben nicht an infektionszahlen nicht an
instanzen an sondern nur daran eine
akute gefahr für das gesundheitssystem
abzuwenden und die hat es in nordrhein
westfalen jedenfalls selbst auf dem
höhepunkt der del tabelle nicht gegeben
wir waren immer in der lage auch
patienten aus anderen bundesländern
einfliegen zu lassen auch aus
europäischen nachbarländern da sieht man
wie hoch die hürde ist damit lösen wir
ein problem der masken pflicht in der
schule leider nicht das hat der bund so
gewollt man wollte diese signale senden
und bringt damit viele leute in der tat
in verunsicherung wie würden sie das
machen jetzt haben wir zwei jahre
pandemie hinter es bleibt immer noch die
verwirrungen es bleibt weiterhin die
angst und es bleibt weiterhin die
befürchtung ist kommt wahrscheinlich
noch eine variante und noch eine
variante muss man nicht irgendwann mal
ausbrechen und sagen gut zurück zur
menschlichkeit zurück zum miteinander
zurück zum vertrauen auch in die bürger
spricht nichts gegen vertrauen und
mitmenschlichkeit und trotzdem kann man
ja gerade weil man solidarisch und
weimar mit menschlich ist sich selbst
und die anderen schützen und eine maske
tragen das eine hat ja es sieht ja nicht
im widerspruch zum anderen wichtig ist
dass wir jetzt nicht wie im letzten jahr
im frühling sagen ach das ist jetzt
vorbei wir lassen wir alles hausen und
im herbst müssen wir uns gegenseitig die
vorwürfe machen nicht aufgepasst zu
haben und steht dann in die nächste
welle das ist das worum es bei all den
diskussionen gibt um basisschutz um hot
spots auch um die impfpflicht dass wir
in den dritten winter der pandemie gut
vorbereitet reingehen die regeln die der
bund jetzt gemacht hat lassen nichts
gutes erahnen die impfpflicht muss man
sagen auch nicht unbedingt es scheint
dieser es würde dir irgendwie
durchkommen vielleicht versucht man auch
über 60 irgendwie hin zu konstruieren er
bringt das überhaupt noch etwas alle
ministerpräsidenten auch der kanzler
wollten die impfpflicht aber die
bundesregierung war nicht in der lage
sich auf einen entwurf zu einigen
deswegen gibt es aus der ampel jetzt
verschiedene varianten die werden jetzt
in diesen stunden im kompromiss wege
zusammen geschoben was ich gar nicht an
der pandemischen entwicklung auch gar
nicht an dem orientiert was man da
vielleicht im herbst erwarten muss 18
war keine mehrheit für zu finden 50
jahren keine mehrheit für zu finden
jetzt versucht man es mal mit 60 ich
empfehle den blick mal auf den unions
vorschlag zu richten nämlich jetzt alles
zu klären was man administrativ
grundsätzlich strukturell für eine
impfpflicht brauch und sobald man klar
sieht welche variante gibt es im herbst
welche menschen sind davon vielleicht
schwer betroffen und welchen impfstoff
haben wir wir verpflichten ja zum impfen
aber welchen impfstoff haben wir dann um
auf diese variante zu reagieren dann
diese details zu klären das scheint mir
ein kluger vorschlag zu sein ich hoffe
die ampel kann sich dafür erwärmen
klaren sieg wir werden sehen der
bundestag ist ja gerade schwer dabei das
zu erarbeiten und ich hoffe auf das
beste wir waren auch über den
bundespräsidenten rené hat fehler
eingeräumt ganz kleine vergangenheit in
seiner russlandpolitik das hat zu einem
großen vertrauensverlust bei den bürgern
geführt jeder dritte deutsche sagt
deshalb steinmeier glaubwürdigkeit
gekostet
stimmen sie zu
das mag sein ich finde wenn jemand einen
fehler eingesteht und das war ja fehler
einer ganzen generation insbesondere bei
der sozialdemokratie dann ist das erst
mal aus meiner sicht kein zeichen von
schwäche sondern von stärke also jetzt
im bundespräsident in frage zu stellen
in dieser krise halte ich nicht für
angezeigt der gesamten sozialdemokratie
wir blicken da auch noch einmal zurück
auf die frühere bundeskanzlerin hat auch
sie da an glaubwürdigkeit eingebüßt dann
wissen sie ich war bei manchen
entscheidungen ja durchaus dabei und
habe sie da auch verfolgt ist war nach
fukushima so dass es einen breiten
gesellschaftlichen konsens gab aus der
atomenergie auszusteigen
das heißt wir machen es anders als
andere länder den übergang zu gestalten
von der kohleverstromung beispielsweise
hin zu den erneuerbaren wir sind die
einzigen die das gleichzeitig machen
will mit dem atomausstieg weil sie nach
fukushima in deutschland diese
aufgeheizte debatte haben angeführt
übrigens von grünen und sozialdemokraten
das muss man noch mal sagen dürfen der
druck war so groß dass man dann gesagt
hat wir machen auch noch den
atomausstieg die folge war dass man gas
brauchte das war am ende die konsequenz
aus den entscheidungen die gesellschaft
politisch so gewollt waren das jetzt
angela merkel vor die füße zu kippen ist
ein bisschen wohlfeil
es morgen wieder mpk diesmal aber der
große flüchtlings gipfel und haben sich
so viele menschen in deutschland
solidarisch gezeigt sie öffnen haus und
tierversuchen familien zu unterstützen
und dennoch hat man in all diesen wochen
nicht geklärt wer zeit jetzt dafür wer
ist zuständig wenn man hat das gefühl
alle deutschen mit anpacken wird diese
frage offen gehalten wir arbeiten unter
hochdruck daran diese frage zu klären
die kommunen tun was in ihrer macht
steht auch viele bürger wachsen wieder
über sich hinaus das ist wirklich
großartig in nordrhein westfalen haben
wie 1,6 milliarden zur verfügung
gestellt um das thema im ersten moment
mal zu adressieren die finanzierung
sicherzustellen aber jetzt muss auch der
bund seinen worten taten folgen lassen
und das tun was in seiner macht steht
darüber verhandeln gerade und ich hoffe
dass wir da auch morgen zu einem
ergebnis kommen die kommunen brauchen
verlässlichkeit die aufgabe ist so groß
weil so viele frauen und kinder kommen
weil für die kinder auch beschulung
organisieren müssen kitas organisieren
müssen wir müssen den helfern helfen
damit wir alle gemeinsam diese große
aufgabe bewältigen können hendrik wüst
vielen herzlichen dank für ihren besuch
hier im studio dankeschön